president biden's big foreign giveaway
tour is
even worse than we thought now not only
is he just giving the europeans
everything they want on trade
on climate on defense he's also letting
china off the hook on kovid
now the joint statement from today's u.s
eu summit calls for a
transparent evidence-based and
expert-led who
convene phase two study on the origins
of coven 19 that is
free from interference joining me now is
ohio congressman jim
jordan and former trump white house
chief of staff mark meadows
mark if they think the w-h-o
is capable of conducting a truly
independent investigation
they're either dumb or totally complicit
in this chinese cover-up which is it
well i can tell you joe biden is not
reading his briefings that he's getting
his intelligence briefings every morning
if he could make a public statement like
that to believe
that that china is all of a sudden going
to miraculously be transparent and say
we're going to help you get to the
origin of this when they've been on
their own propaganda
trying to blame the united states
military
blame everybody but themselves uh it was
just a very ignorant statement for the
president to make
and congressman jordan i thought uh this
was really interesting because you've
been raising
questions about john kerry's true role
in the biden white house so in a letter
to carrie you write it is a paramount
importance that we conduct oversight
over your position as the special
presidential envoy for climate
and how the position will impact the
interests of the us especially where the
role appears to intersect
with the u.s response to hostile foreign
regimes such as
the chinese communist party all right so
what do you think old john kerry is
going to say to you for that uh
that letter and what what's your what's
your suspicion here about what kerry's
doing
well he's been to china once already i
mean john kerry the same guy who gave us
the iran deal just what we needed is
another iran deal with with china so to
speak so
we're nervous about this but the bigger
concern for me with john kerry is
he wasn't elected to anything he wasn't
senate confirmed this idea they have
unelected people in our government
making big decisions
we've already lived through a year of
that with dr fauci
and everything he did to our country and
to our businesses and to our first
amendment liberties
so i think there's a host of concerns
with john kerry being the climate
envoy going to china and negotiating
nuclear deals negotiating climate deals
we saw what happened in the previous
administration when he was involved in
these areas
i think americans are rightly concerned
that's why we wrote this letter
and mark back to the uh the big biden
giveaway
he's also surrendering in this i think
it's a 17-year
boeing airbus dispute airbus is the
french
jetliner manufacturer they get huge
subsidies from france
and biden agreed to suspend tariffs for
five years cnbc reported last week that
the eu
was pressing the white house to reach a
deal to end the trade tariffs
imposed during the trump administration
mark
boeing boeing is is i'm sorry screwed
here
are they not well listen joe biden has
been tougher on the american worker than
he has been on our european allies and
and you have to look no further than
saying we're going to do away with any
of the tariffs
and yet airbus continues to enjoy a
special privilege that other companies
don't enjoy
and all of a sudden to go over this on
this giveaway tour
that's what it really is it's a giveaway
on terrace as a giveaway on climate
it's a giveaway to the chinese and
ultimately it's a giveaway
to our european allies that would say
we're no longer america first
we're here to make sure that it's
europeans first
and and it's a sad commentary uh
tomorrow
the putin meeting uh congressman jordan
were apparently supposed to just be in
awe of joe
biden's foreign policy acumen sitting
across the table from putin
with given everything that's happened
china got off
got off scot-free europeans are in the
driver's seat what is putin thinking
well i think the big takeaway is and
this is unfortunate but i think our
adversaries see
uh smell and and and you know see
weakness and smell weakness from
from the biden administration we saw
this on display up in anchorage a few
months ago
when our secretary of state tony blinken
was set across from his chinese
counterpart
and the chinese counterpart just smacked
him around and basically lectured him
and said all kinds of things basically
reciting what the left says
in the democrat party today and our
secretary of state of the united states
did nothing to push back that would
never that would never happen to mike
pompeo in a president trump
administration
we all know it we see the same thing our
adversary sees so
i'm nervous about what what actually
happens in this um but
you know we'll just have to wait and see
nordstrom too mark uh
was that a big gift to russia or what
well yeah i mean
we essentially did away with any kind of
uh tariffs on
on the gas pipeline for the russians and
yet we're killing the keystone pipeline
here in the united states
you know joe biden continues every
single time
to pick the wrong side of the equation
and jim's exactly right when we start to
look at all of this
they can smell the fear and and it's sad
uh gentlemen thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else